il se passe quelque chose en grèce c'est
d'abord la croissance revient en grèce
elle pourrait être de 3% à peu près en
2017 et 2018 ce qui est aussi une
perspective je crois positive pour le
peuple grec qui a tellement souffert et
qui a perdu près de 27 % de son pib avec
un taux de chômage qui est insupportable
notamment de la jeunesse c'est pas
possible
et la deuxième chose c'est que le
gouvernement grec fait des réformes
sap a été spontanée ça n'a pas été
évident mais ils prennent leur
responsabilité ils jouent le jeu et ma
thèse mon attitude c'est de considérer
que s'ils prennent leurs responsabilités
s'ils jouent le jeu
nous devons prendre nos responsabilités
noé qui sait les partenaires de la grèce
au sein de leur groupe les autres pays
membres de la zone euro
c'est le fonds monétaire international
c'est la banque centrale européenne
c'est la commission et oui je pense
qu'il faut qu'on envisage une
restructuration de la dette grecque
dans le cas d'un projet global ou une
approche globale où il y aurait le
programme qui se déroule les réformes
qui se font la confiance des
investisseurs qui revient la croissance
qui redémarre l'emploi qui repart et
dans ce contexte là oui je plaide pour
un accord global sur la grèce d'ici la
fin d'année